presidential elections often it's the
same old versus the same old and usually
between men but this year in Brazil it's
a little different two women both with
radical roots are frontrunners to become
the president of the seventh largest
economy in the world one of them already
is Dilma Rousseff she's up against this
lady Marina Silva so who are they and
what are they about
let's find out a little serious a lot of
determined and elected in 2011 that's
President Dilma Rousseff chancer
national politics in 2003 when former
president Lula da Silva of the Workers
Party appointed her as energy minister
he then hand-picked her to follow him as
a party's presidential candidate in 2010
and she won but she wasn't always a
mainstream politician in the sixties
Rousseff with a guerilla in Brazil's
movement against the military
dictatorship she spent over two years in
prison where she was tortured as
President Rousseff has continued Luis
policies specifically using profits from
nationalized oil for social spending
thanks to the workers party's programs
and the raising of the minimum wage
Brazil seen a huge decrease in extreme
poverty and undernourishment this year
the country was finally taken off the
world hunger map Dilma also stuck it to
the United States last year when she
found out the NSA had been spying on her
and her government Gigi Ola sounded a
2-month it does give a Dodge City mm-hmm
but not everyone's happy with recess
some blame her for Brazil's current
recession and say she isn't business
friendly in US and in the past two years
millions of taken to the streets to
protest the cost of transportation for
health care evictions police violence
corruption and the nearly 12 billion
dollars spent on the World Cup still
recep's biggest rival doesn't come from
a more conservative party
it comes from Marina Silva she's got the
support of many were fed up with
politics as usual especially youth she's
a Socialist Party's candidate and was
originally running as vice Prez to this
man when he was
in a plane crash in August in less than
a month Silva's popularity soared
pushing her past other political
contenders to be neck and neck with
Dilma she says she wants to do with the
Workers Party does only better vamos go
hey zero zeros principal ventricle some
kid drainage in a pas de da e prego
Casares a would you propose a Familia
and looking at what she's accomplished
in life few doubt her determination it's
coming from a poor rural part of the
Brazilian Amazon she taught herself to
read and write and has spent her life
working to protect the rainforest and
workers rights at 36 she became Brazil's
youngest female senator in 2003 she
became environmental minister and passed
laws to slow deforestation but ended up
quiting over the government's not so
sustainable development plans if
president Silva says she would invest
more in wind solar and ethanol and turn
Brazil into a low-carbon economy but her
economic policies might not be so
sustainable for people some say they're
too business friendly and would undo the
progress of the last decade if elected
she be Brazil's first black president
too strong female contenders still in an
extremely Catholic country neither
speaks much about reproductive rights
and bolts have been cagey on gay
marriage who would you vote for the
environmentalists with new ideas or the
incumbent with the know-how one more
download the agent plus mobile app and
join the conversation
available in your App Store now